[Music]
what's up MKBHD here so by Clockwork
Apple just unveiled a bunch of new stuff
at their September event iPhone and
iPhone accessories my video about the
new iPhone 14 series is already live
link below that like button go watch it
over there if you want a look at those
this video is on the iPhone accessories
which low-key I think I think were more
interesting than the iPhones themselves
so first we got the new airpods Pro
still 249 dollars like the last ones and
still basically the same design but a
lot of internal improvements add up to a
potentially much better experience so
there's new drivers the new H2 chip
inside there's two times stronger noise
cancellation a new longer six hour
battery life on a single charge and
touch volume controls on the stocks
where the force touch sensors are and
there's even a new adaptive transparency
mode basically just building on Apple's
gigantic lead with their already
god-like transparency mode by detecting
like extra loud noises and trimming them
so so if you walk past the construction
zone the mics aren't going to pump in
the super loud Jackhammer noises but the
best thing honestly is probably the new
case I think basically Apple just
realized how often people lose the case
including myself so it's a lot easier
now to not lose it or to find it so
there's a hook on the side for Lanyards
now plus I added a speaker on the bottom
so you can find it when it's lost by
emitting a sound and it's all now in a
fully magsafe compatible case that can
also now charge with an Apple Watch
charger the earbud Wars are spicy right
now there's a lot of good options out
there these are obviously on the pricier
end but given how good they sound
quality is how good the transparency
mode is and how well it works with the
iPhone these will probably do pretty
well but I'm going to review them I'm
going to check them out but what you're
really here for is the new Apple watch
lineup because that's what I titled the
video but that's also the most
interesting stuff so that is the new
Apple watch SE a new Apple watch series
8 and a new Apple watch Ultra so the
Apple watch SE slots in at the bottom of
the lineup at 250 bucks to replace the
old Watch series 3 that they were still
selling and it's better in pretty much
every way it's got a redesigned color
matching back case a 30 larger screen
than that old watch and the S8 sip that
makes a lot of sense then the Apple
Watch series 8 is in the middle it's a
very minor but very reasonable upgrade
to the series seven so it's in the same
design it gives it a new temperature
sensor which is useful for advanced
cycle tracking and retrospective
ovulation estimates for women it gives
it some new GeForce sensors for crash
detection so it can automatically tell
when you've been in a car crash and it
can call for help if you don't respond
to the prompt on the screen no idea how
I'm going to test that but I believe you
and it gives it a new low power mode
that can help extend battery life when
you're in a pinch boom same price 3.99
for GPS only 4.99 for cellular cool but
then there's a new watch at the high end
the Apple watch Ultra it basically looks
like they uh took a regular Apple watch
and sent it to the gym so the result is
a beefed up 49 millimeter watch it's the
biggest bra brightest display ever in an
Apple Watch which can get up to 2 000
nits the display up top is flat and has
just just a tiny bit of a lip on the
edge to protect the sapphire crystal
cover and the digital crown on the side
is bigger and thicker with this added
Crown guard and a button that sticks out
for even normal so it's easier to hit
with gloves on then on the other side
there's a second speaker and additional
microphones added for additional volume
and better mic quality and windy
environments there's a new button a big
bright orange action button this is a
customizable button that you can set to
do any number of different things like
starting a workout or letting up the
whole screen white to be a flashlight
and then while you're in an app it can
serve different functions inside that
app and by the way this is the only spec
there's only one Apple watch Ultra just
this titanium and ceramic they all have
cellular and they all have this bright
orange action button so you know
aesthetically it feels like you know
when we first saw these rumors of a pro
watch maybe coming they really could
only go go two ways they could start
with a super ruggedized military-grade
Garmin level watch and then try to bring
it down and like amplify it or they
could start with a regular Apple watch
and ruggedize that and they clearly went
with option two which makes for this
chunky looking Apple watch but still a
pretty familiar looking watch what's
notable though is it doesn't feel heavy
the titanium made it actually feel much
lighter on the wrist than I expected so
yeah while it's definitely easier to
call this one a chunker it's it's thick
with maybe three or even four C's just
know it it could have definitely been
bigger now there's a bunch of features
you know how I think they made this
watch I think they they took a bunch of
extreme high performance athletes and
asked them all how many of you use an
Apple Watch and the ones that raised
their hand and said I don't use the
watch it just can't hang with me they
took those people brought them to Apple
Park and interrogated them to figure out
what they needed to change about the
Apple watch to make it keep up with what
they do so they for sure talk to some
divers who are definitely like yeah this
thing is it's waterproof but it's not
waterproof enough to go down way as low
as I go and be a dive computer and then
Apple went and made this watch wr100
water resistant so you can dive down
theoretically to 100 meters with it and
through extra sensors in there to make
it a real proper dive computer for a lot
of people I think they talk to
Mountaineers who hike in like white out
conditions and then from that you get
extreme temperature ruggedness you get
the ability to add waypoints in the
compass app so if you ever need to find
your way back someplace that you can't
visually see you can always use the
watch for it and they tossed in an 86
decibel siren from the new larger
speaker which is Extremely Loud and can
sort of send out an SOS signal to people
nearby and also uh dual band GPS this is
a feature you don't see as often as
smart watches but can massively improve
accuracy and also help out if you're
going through some GPS dead zones I
think they talked to marathoners who
probably all just said yeah the watch
dies before the end of a normal Marathon
so I can't use it and then of course the
ultra now with its new thicker case has
room for much more battery how much more
exactly well on stage Apple said 36
hours and they also said 18 hours about
the normal Apple watch so I'm just doing
the mental math of like how long this
normally lasts me which is about a day
and a half and so the ultra is double so
it feels like with normal use it can be
about a three day battery and then they
also said it could get up to 60 hours
with the new battery optimization
feature that's not coming till later
this year
I don't know exactly what that means or
what it will entail but if I just do the
math again that could net out to about
five days of regular use with that mode
on but that's that's purely theoretical
at this point I definitely have to use
it but either way they claim that
marathoner can now not only finish a
marathon but they can do an entire Iron
Man which is a two and a half mile swim
a hundred mile bike ride and a 27 mile
marathon back to back and track the
whole thing with heart rate and GPS with
battery to spare that is impressive so
this is definitely living up to the
ultra name no question about that and I
know when we all see these features we
start to think about pricing a little
bit so again there were some rumors
there were some talks that this might
end up being like a thousand dollar
watch to start which seemed crazy at
first to me but then I had flashbacks of
like that ten thousand dollar gold Apple
watch Edition so it wasn't entirely out
of the aroma possibility but it turns
out this one is actually priced entirely
reasonably it starts at actually there's
only one price One spec but it's 7.99
that's still pricey obviously but that
just for context uh Garmin Phoenix a
very competitive popular smart watch is
900 bucks uh 800 bucks I think for for
the smallest one but Apple's not usually
the one doing the undercutting but then
on top of that there were also some new
faces and bands specifically for this
Ultra watch uh the way finder faces are
pretty sweet and give just a lot of
relevant information to someone who
might be in the middle of something like
hiking you know there's a compass
elevation
Etc and then there's three special new
watch bands a Trail Loop for endurance
athletes the Alpine Loop and The Ocean
band for high-speed water sports all of
these are pretty unique and actually
very impressive both durability wise and
comfort wise like these are really good
bands and so fun fact I was just kind of
wondering and I had to actually check I
did take the bands off of the ultra and
put them on the smaller watches and they
seem to work just fine so just from this
experience audience I'm going to say
that it seems like backwards
compatibility with the bands is a green
light so the number one question I've
been getting since this announcement is
am I gonna get one like okay it's for
explorers Adventures endurance athletes
a lot of you guys know I play Ultimate
Frisbee and I do wear my watch while
playing and practicing most of the time
so am I in the Target demographic for
this uh yes and no I you know they
showed a couple obvious examples
mountaineering biking Iron Mans and
things like that for me like I would
love the extra battery life and for
certain workouts and things like that
having better GPS and being able to do
more workouts before the thing dies
would be nice but it's for me like it's
still an everyday watch it's an Apple
Watch like you still have to wear it all
the rest of the time too and for me it
is approaching the sort of like too big
to be able to pull off normally on the
wrist it's not huge obviously I couldn't
wear a garment every day either I don't
think with my skinny wrists but like fun
fact I wore this black Apple watch to
the Met Gala and I think it was okay
like it turned out fine you can dress it
up hide it under a cuff but I don't
think you can do all that with the ultra
here's how I think of it on the waveform
podcast this week Andrew my co-host said
I think he explained it kind of
perfectly with the summary which is the
Apple watch Ultra is like the GoPro of
Apple watches you see a cool commercial
and you think oh that is sick like this
super durable camera is going to capture
my Amazing Adventures I'm gonna have the
sickest footage ever and then you get
one and then you use it maybe once or
twice and the footages are right and
then it just kind of sits in a drawer
Gathering dust and this watch
most people don't need but it would be
sick like the commercials are sick and I
think if you are one of those athletes
who I was just talking about in this
video like you're definitely going to be
able to take advantage of the watch but
for most people also the regular Apple
watch will be fine and for me it
probably will my biggest annoyance with
all the watches actually is something
that Casey neistat actually just brought
up on Twitter which is literally just
that if it's if you're sweating a lot or
if it's raining or if you've got long
sleeves during a workout it tends to
mess with the screen it touches the
screen even if you have theater mode on
it just lights up the screen and messes
with the workout Data Tracking I want
them to just fix that and I'd be cool
with probably any of the watches but for
the extreme for the adventurers and for
those with Deep Pockets this is going to
be a pretty sick watch this is it's very
it's competitive with a lot of the other
rugged eye smart watches out there but
it's key Advantage being it's also an
Apple Watch you can also wear it every
day and it's also going to work really
well with that iPhone that you probably
already have so that's what Ultra that's
it for the video thanks for watching let
me know what you think too if the if the
ultra is right for you if you have a
certain situation you use it in all
right catch you guys later peace
[Music]